you are not going to ascend in any
organization without a sponsor this
person who's going to pound the table on
your behalf this is a sponsor it is the
critical relationship in your career now
I'm asked all the time you know how did
how do you get one every time you
deliver upon an assignment above
people's expectations you generate
performance currency strong performance
currency raises your level of visibility
in the environment such that a sponsor
may be attracted to you so it is
important that you invest the time to
connect to engage and to get to know the
people that are in your environment and
more importantly to give them the
opportunity to know you because once
they know you is a higher probability
that when you approach them to ask them
to be your sponsor they will in fact
answer in the affirmative